i
[Música]
ah
y aquí
[Música]
hoy quiero compartir algo de mi vida
personal algo que se ha convertido en un
estilo de vida para quiero hablarles de
persistir de persistir hasta alcanzar
las metas propuestas también de la
persistencia como un hilo que me ha
permitido tejer redes redes que han
transformado otras vidas no sólo la mía
por eso esta historia no sólo trata de
cómo ser persistente me ha permitido
surgir en diferentes campos sino que
también como ser persistente me ha
permitido impactar otras vidas y
ayudarlas a surgir inicialmente quiero
decir que soy un científico enamorado de
la idea entender me formé como físico y
después incursión en el fabuloso mundo
de la ciencia los materiales actualmente
soy investigador de un grupo de altísimo
prestigio donde hacemos investigación de
alto nivel en temas tan relevantes como
energía solar
trabajamos en aprendizaje de máquina que
es lo que se llama como machine learning
en este caso es para el descubrimiento
de una medicina para un tipo de
tratamiento de cáncer y ccoo dirijo un
proyecto en colaboración con la
multinacional de la india'
la textil y la universidad de toronto
quiero recalcar que el resultado de
estas investigaciones no sólo son
relevantes en términos académicos y
empresariales sino también en la parte
del desarrollo social gracias a estas
investigaciones he tenido la fortuna de
compartir lugares científicos y
empresariales y también de negociar con
multinacionales que tienen este tipo de
tecnologías en la mira me declaró por
otro lado un músico apasionado tocó el
violín desde los 6 años y también un
emprendedor social entusiasta durante
las múltiples facetas de mi vida he
encontrado que hay una fórmula que me ha
ayudado a surgir y ya terminar mis metas
de una forma exitosa hoy quiero
compartir con ustedes esta fórmula que
me permitió estar en sitios y en
situaciones inimaginables que me
parecían que no iban a ser posible hoy
quiero compartir esta fórmula con
ustedes se trata de persistir con
disciplina humildad voluntad
liderazgo está idea de persistir me ha
llevado a trabajar en grandes institutos
de instituciones en alemania hasta el
instituto en eeuu como el tecnológico de
massachusetts o la universidad de
harvard pero también me ha ayudado a que
otras personas tengan también este mismo
tipo de oportunidad conectar a mi país
colombia con destacados científicos e
impactar en algunas comunidades de niños
y jóvenes tal como reiteró siempre es
aquí donde hay que apostar para tener un
mejor futuro les voy a confesar no creo
que nos volvamos persistentes de un día
para otro
esa es una habilidad que no aparece de
forma espontánea como por arte de magia
lo que sí creo es que es una habilidad
que se cultiva se fortalece se entrena
esto lo he visto en las biografías
yo amo leer biografías porque uno ve las
aventuras y las desventuras de las
personas que ha transcendido en la
historia
a partir de las biografías ahora lleva
una agenda escrita en la que pongo mis
metas que quiero realizar día a día
también creo que todas las personas
tenemos habilidades y talentos que son
innatos todos tenemos unos dones que nos
hacen únicos estos dones nos ayudan a
fluir en la vida lo que sí creo es que
esos dones no son suficientes para
surgir es necesario complementarlo con
otras cualidades que para mi caso la
persistencia hace parte de ese grupo de
habilidades
ese grupo de habilidades por las cuales
nos tenemos que esforzar para
aprenderlas apropiar las y sobre todo
volverlas un hábito de nuestras vidas
permítanme contarles porque he llegado a
esta conclusión desde joven me destacado
en ámbitos académicos tocó el violín
desde que tengo seis años y hay muchas
personas a mi alrededor pensando que yo
era un tipo brillante y talentoso y
hasta había gente que pensaba que yo era
un tipo está bien parecido
que cualquier puerta que yo tocara sólo
con esto si yo abrir de forma inmediata
fácilmente pues resulta que no ha sido
así ni cerca de ser así vaya decepción
con el paso de los años los altos y los
bajos y los golpes duras de la vida
comprendí que para alcanzar las metas
propuestas requería de algo más de esos
dones signatus comprendí que aún con
talentos y recursos es necesario
persistir para surgir la historia que
les quiero contar hoy comienza con mis
padres
álvaro y luz marina mi madre falleció
cuando nosotros éramos aún adolescentes
vivíamos en el exterior mi padre mi
madre estaban haciendo el doctorado
quedamos con un vacío en el corazón
mi padre con todo el dolor del alma nos
dijo cuando empiezas algo el respeto a
ti mismo respeto a uno mismo terminarlo
y acabó su doctorado con una nota
excelente yo lo aplico como modelo de
vida él es mi principal sistema de
persistencia mi madre era una mujer
extraordinaria apasionada por la música
por el tenis y sobre todo por las
matemáticas recuerdo ahora con agrado
que uno de sus tópicos consistía en el
estudio de las habilidades matemáticas
de los niños en situación de calle
ver esta solidaridad y dedicación
marcaron un camino para ver las
matemáticas como una herramienta de
impacto social una para la persona más
persistente y disciplinada que yo
conozco nunca ha dejado estudiar ese
grado como físico y fue profesor de la
universidad del valle en física y fue el
fundador principal de la carpa
melquiades la carpa de mercedes era un
museo interactivo de la ciencia y las
matemáticas de orden gratuito para
jóvenes y niños del suroccidente
colombiano en la carpa me impresionó la
capacidad de los niños de observar y
predecir al igual que como muchos años
antes lo había hecho mi madre este fue
mi otro acercamiento al emprendimiento
científico social ese acercamiento fue
más con los jóvenes la emoción de
aprender ver un cambio real en el
pensamiento de todos y el amor por
conocer y sobre todo el amor por dar
me abrió las puertas para pensar que
quería dedicarme realmente a esto la
frase mi papá es siempre conocer para
prever prever para actuar
cuando acabe mi carrera de físico tenía
la firme intención de continuar mis
estudios de postgrado en las mejores
instituciones y universidades del mundo
él va a compensar al aplique escribí
busque llame a más de 60 universidades e
institutos obteniendo respuestas
negativas por muchos años en el 2013
tuve una oportunidad de ir a mejorar mi
inglés en inglaterra estuve viendo en
casa a los profesores de hecho uno de
los dos profesores se había ganado una
medalla fields que es el equivalente al
nobel en matemática a mí me impresionó y
ahí aprendí que aún siendo muy grande se
podía realmente ser muy humilde
al no tener afirmativa por cuatro años o
un poco más continúe aplicando hasta que
al final fui aceptado en un excelente
instituto
aprender
sobre un campo que me permitió surgir no
solamente en ciencia sino sobre la parte
de emprendimiento social
cuando empecé mi doctorado estaba
ansioso estaba asustado no sabía que me
iba a enfrentar
tuve la fortuna de dar con un tutor
excelente de una calidad humana
impresionante
me di cuenta que persistir había valió
la pena fue tanta mi persistencia y mi
emoción en esto que con él
sometimos alrededor de unos 30 artículos
durante lo que fue mi doctorado y poco
más sin embargo me di cuenta que hacía
me faltaba algo algo me hacía falta
yo quería transformar el mundo generar
huella y generar más impacto en la
sociedad pero les confieso no sabía qué
camino a tomar después hice parte de un
grupo de diferentes personas de
diferentes ámbitos del conocimiento que
me ayudaron a recordar mi objetivo de
volver a lo social y conectar a mi país
con investigadores de otras partes
después de esto organicé un congreso en
cali mi ciudad donde hicimos contactos
intercambios y colaboraciones y la
verdad a mí esto de tener redes me
empezaba a gustar aún más esta
plataforma que utilizamos en el congreso
la he venido empleando especialmente
ahorita para trabajar con niños y
jóvenes de mi país es lo que hace parte
de algo
se llama la democratización del
conocimiento es generar acceso a
oportunidades a la educación a la
ciencia en un país donde realmente esto
escasea
los niños y jóvenes con los que he
trabajado han tenido la gran oportunidad
de visitar espacios de investigación muy
reconocidos mundialmente además hasta
hablar con grandes directores y premios
nobel
no te lo puedes imaginar los chicos por
ejemplo que nos visitaron a nosotros en
alemania muchos de ellos nunca habían
cogido un avión y ahorita tener la
oportunidad de sentarse en una mesa con
un premio nobel con un director de un
instituto de los grandes hitos alemanes
la etnia indígena con la que trabajamos
en el norte de colombia que envió celdas
solares orgánicas al espacio con un
proyecto colaborativo con cubos en el
espacio nasa fue realmente algo que le
cambia la vida muchos de estos chicos
ahorita quieren hacer carreras
científicas de hecho hay un chico hay un
niño que se está postulando para ser
astronauta tendríamos el primer
astronauta colombiano salido de uno de
estos talleres de ciencia
esto ha tomado tanta fuerza que hemos
logrado colaboraciones entre comunidades
de diferentes regiones del país
entidades no solamente en eeuu sino que
también en canadá y en europa seguimos
enviando celdas al espacio pero ahora de
hecho vamos a enviar un robot hecho por
niños
hemos ganado concursos internacionales
con los niños y sigo trabajando en
proyectos que conectan la ciencia con
los contextos sociales ahora soy el
líder de un emprendimiento social de
base científica que tiene como bandera
la co-creación y el diálogo de saberes
después de persistir para alcanzar mi
sueño de estar en instituciones de
investigación de alto prestigio en
harvard en el instituto tecnológico de
massachusetts institución en alemania me
di cuenta que la ciencia tiene que ir de
la mano sobre todo con lo humano y que
llegue acá para darme cuenta que no todo
se trata de estándares
sigo buscando la excelencia y sugieren
ambientes sobre todo empáticos que
apoyen los proyectos sociales la
persistencia de forma igual
la resiliencia me convence que la
ciencia no solo era una forma personal
de entender el mundo y el camino que me
permitió surgir sino que también en
medio de mi persistencia personal para
alcanzar grandes estándares descubro la
ciencia como una herramienta para
conectar personas y lograr cambios
positivos en las comunidades de mi país
es así como entendí que toda esa
persistencia para surgir no se trataba
sólo de mí sino de lo que puedo hacer
por los demás los invito a persistir por
sus sueños por sus metas recordando que
lo que logren por ustedes hoy también
pueden impactar directa o indirectamente
en la vida a los demás y persistiendo
surgimos y persistiendo sobre todo
mejoramos el mundo que nos rodea
[Música]